القوه العزيمه الامل انا اسمي ايه الله
محيسن انا مهندسه ميكانيكا ويوغي
[موسيقى]
ثاني سنه في الجامعه اليوم كان خلص
وزي كل يوم في الفتره دي كانت الدنيا
حزينه شويه بالنسبه لي عشان انا كنت عارفه
ان انا مش هاقدر اكمل في الجامعه
[موسيقى]
وزي نهايه اي يوم بروح الجنينه بتاعه
الارض
[موسيقى]
بقول ربنا وانا عملت كل حاجه واقدر عليها
دلوقتي الباقي بتاعك وانا راضيه بك
بس انا مش هاستسلم انا هافضل احاول مره
واثنين وثلاثه وفي اللحظه دي حسيت انه انا
بقى عندك كميه قوه
وبليس انه لا انا متاكده ان انا هاكمل
وانا هخلي نفسي اكمل
ايه بعدها بشهرين مثلا
بتاعتي
اللي خليتني بعد كده اعرف اكمل
الخمس سنين بتوعي في الجامعه ومن بعدها
خلاص فكره انه ما فيش امل ده مش في
القاموس بتاعي انا اي حاجه مهما كانت
الساعات انا عارفه ومتاكده
والعزيمه والقمل
[موسيقى]
انا فعلا عايزه اضيف انه
بينج ومن هي بجد مش حاجه مش لميتيشن خالص
لو اي حاجه انا ممكن اكون في شغل مجهد
جسديه بس انا دخلت فيها عشان انا عارفه
كبيره قوي ما حدش بياخذ باله منها انه
احنا
بنضيف حاجه للشغل اكثر ما بناخذ احنا في
وسط
الميل الدومنات
[موسيقى]
كثيره قوي
في الشغل دي حاجه حلوه وانا فعلا مش عايزه
البنات
لان في الاول وفي الاخر احنا كلنا بني
ادمين
وهنقدر نكسر الستريو تايب دي مع الوقت
حاجات كبيره قوي بس انا حلمي فعلا ان انا
اكون راضيه على اللي انا باعمله
ده اهم حاجه بالنسبه لي يعني انا مش حلمي
منصب مش حلمي اا فلوس مش حلوين
[موسيقى]